leviathan wakes is the first book in the
expanse
a sci-fi adventure mystery drama in
space
in our last video we explained the
cultures and politics of the series
but what happens in leviathan wakes and
what does it mean
eight years ago a corporation called
protogen explored
phoebe a small moon of saturn and they
found that phoebe
is no moon it's actually a weapon
created by
aliens billions of years ago phoebe was
launched across interstellar space
carrying a kind of virus called the
proto-molecule
the proto-molecule infects and changes
life forms for some
alien purpose protogen executive dresden
tries to control the proto-molecule
to use it so humans can rewrite their
own biology
and to make protogen rich and powerful
dresden studied the protomolecule by
infecting
people on phoebe who all died the
molecules seemed to need
more biomass so dresden and protogen
plan an experiment to infect
eros feeding a million people to the
proto-molecule
they put some molecule on a stealth ship
called the anubis and send it at
eros but along the way the anubis meets
julie mao
julie is the daughter of jul pierre mao
a powerful businessman
his company mao kwakowski secretly works
with protogen planning the eros
experiment
julie wants freedom and independence
from her rich family so she leaves home
and joins the opa
a political group fighting for belter
rights julie works with opa leader
anderson dawes on
series and she pilots a courier ship
called the scopuli
julie finds out that her father is
transporting some
weapon so she and the opa intercept the
anubis
but the scopuli is overwhelmed the
cruise taken prisoner on the anubis
and julie's locked in storage then the
anubis uses their empty scopuli
as a trap they plant a martian
transmitter on the scopula
and send a distress bacon the sirenam
scopuli are the islands of the
sirens of greek mythology who lure
sailors to their deaths
because the scopuli lures a nearby
belter ship called the canterbury
then the anubis destroys the cant but
the martian transmitter they planted
makes it look like
mars killed the cat protogen does this
to create
conflict between mars and the belt to
distract everyone from the eros
experiment
but protogen underestimates the cat and
its executive officer
james holden holden is from earth and he
served in the un navy
the space force but he got disillusioned
with the
authoritarian unnn so he left and got
work on the canterbury
holden's an idealist he believes in
truth and justice and doing the right
thing
he's a natural leader self-sacrificing a
classic hero type
when the count is destroyed holden leads
the survivors naomi
amos alex and shed holden helps bring
them together as a team
but he also makes rash decisions he
tries to chase down the anubis to bring
them to justice which would probably
just get them
killed naomi has to stop him from being
an idiot
but then holden does something even
dumber he makes a broadcast telling the
universe that someone with a martian
transmitter killed the cat
it is the truth and holden believes
people need to know but
spreading this news creates conflict
between mars and the belt
which is exactly what protogen wants
holden's sense of honesty and justice
helps cause a war holden's also forced
to question his sense of
romance naomi points out that holden has
a habit of treating every little crush
like it's true love
it's only after holden changes his
behavior that he and naomi get together
she helps holden become a more mature
lover as well as a better leader
so from the beginning holden's naive
idealism around love and truth and
justice
are challenged especially by the other
main character
miller miller is a detective for private
security on series
and unlike holden he believes that moral
flexibility is
necessary he'll destroy evidence make
shady deals if that's what it takes to
get [ __ ] done
miller has a complex identity because
he's a belter born on ceres but he works
for an earth-owned company
policing belters so some belters see him
as a traitor to his people
at the start of the book miller finds
that the crime gangs of series are
strangely
inactive lately and siri security's riot
gear
is stolen we later learned that the
reason for this is that protogen hires
series thugs to help run their
experiment on
eros and the thugs take series riot gear
with them
this is a problem for miller when
belters riot over the destruction of the
cat
thanks to holden's broadcast miller gets
assigned a new job
jul pm mao wants julie found and taken
home
at first miller dismisses julie as a
poor little rich girl
but while investigating her activity on
series he starts to respect her
she's capable smart and she's tough
learning jujitsu after being attacked
one time
by joining the opa julie sacrificed a
life of wealth and privilege for a cause
that she believes in
miller is a nihilistic empty man worn
down by the corruption and horror of his
police work
but julie inspires him to believe in
something
miller believes in julie when miller
gets fired for being unreliable
renegade and drunk he loses the career
that had defined him
all he has left as a purpose in life is
finding julie
meanwhile holden a crew are captured by
a martian flagship called the donager
but then the donage is attacked by
protogen stealth ships
holden's crew escapes on a martian ship
except
shed is randomly killed by a stray gauss
round
some of the characters and plot of the
expanse began
as a pen and paper role-playing game run
by ty frank
when the person playing shed left this
game shed's character had to be suddenly
removed
and that's why shed's death comes so
suddenly in the story
anyway protogen destroys the donagher
but mars thinks the belt did it which
leads to war between mars and the belt
so protogen's plan works their false
flag attacks cause a war that distracts
everyone from eros
holden a crew settled in to their new
martian ship
holden names it rosinante this is a
reference to don quixote the story of a
wannabe knight who attacks windmills
thinking they're giants
so the name rossannante evokes adventure
and heroism but
also idealistic silliness which pretty
much
sums up holden the rosie crew take
refuge with fred johnson
an opa leader whose company is building
a giant mormon spaceship called the
nauvoo
through the opa fred worked with the
scopuli and he gets a message connected
to the scopulae from eros
so holden and crew go and investigate
miller follows the rosi crew to eros and
helps them survive an attack by
protogen's men
then together they find julie mao dead
from the proto-molecule because what
happened was after the protegent ship
anubis captured the scopular and
destroyed the cant
their protomolecule sample leaked
killing everyone
on board except for julie in storage
julie later broke out and hid the anubis
then went to eros but she'd been
infected so she slowly horrifically
died alone losing the anubis was a
problem for protogen because they needed
that protomolecule sample for eros
so protegent follows holden to julie and
uses her
infected body as the seed to start the
eros experiment
for crowd control protogen uses those
thugs from series with the stolen riot
gear
who now call themselves kane polomakina
meet for the machine
they fake an emergency and lead the
people of eros into radiation shelters
which are actually used to infect
everyone with the proto-molecule
infected people become zombies the
series thugs fight holden and miller get
irradiated
it's a bad time and amidst all the
suffering and violence
miller starts to welcome death he's
tired and broken and just wants release
from his trauma
and pain his only sense of hope is his
imagination of julie
the ghost of this dead girl he's never
met
miller and holden work together and
escape eros alive but they also
clash over their differences holden
stops miller from shooting an infected
person
says miller doesn't get to decide who
lives and dies
miller criticizes holden for publicly
broadcasting sensitive information
like holden broadcasts evidence
connecting protogen's ships to earth
so then earth attacks mars and destroys
the moon of demos
making the worst war in history even
worse
holden thinks that telling everyone the
truth is the right thing to do
and the best way to make peace but
miller argues that the truth can be
dangerous
you've got to be more strategic to get
good outcomes
there is no right thing to do just a
whole bunch of
maybe a little less wrong so miller
challenges holden's simplistic view of
the world and
helps him to see the complexity and the
shades of grey
miller and the rosie crew find the
anubis where julie had hidden it and
then they destroy it
as symbolic justice for the cat they
also learn about protogen's experiment
on eros
so they team up with fred and the opa to
attack protogen's research base
thoth station thoth was an egyptian god
associated with science and with the
judgment of the dead
holden miller and fred take the station
and confront dresden
the architect of the eros project
instead of
fighting or begging mercy dresden makes
rational arguments why the eros project
should continue
he says studying the proto-molecule is
worth killing a million people
because the power to rewrite biology
would let humans expand to distant stars
he says the proto-molecule proves that
there are hostile aliens out there
and humans will need the power of the
proto-molecule if they face
its creators and besides eros is already
infected so stopping the project won't
save anyone it'll only waste the data
and make those people die for nothing
holden
is disgusted by dresden's cold logic
but he sees that dresden may have a
point
when miller says that people are
actually listening to evil space mengele
he kills dresden on the spot and holden
is outraged that miller would kill
someone in cold blood
says it's inhuman and unjust what about
a trial what makes miller the judge jury
and executioner
miller argues that with dresden's power
and connections he was going to get away
with his crimes
and continue his experiments so killing
dresden had to be done
but holden can't trust someone who
unilaterally headshots people he
disagrees with
so holden kicks miller out of the rosie
crew
and miller is devastated he started to
think of the rosie as his home
his family but now he's alone with
no home no job no friends he feels that
the hard choices he's made to survive
have cut him off from human connection
left him
empty and numb he compares himself to
protogen
miller's only hope for connection and
redemption
is his imagination of julie you belong
with me
she says eros infected with a
protomolecule
does some freaky stuff the bodies of the
people of
eros are re-shaped into cronenbergian
flesh scapes like hieronymus
bosch made real eros broadcasts ghostly
voices
made from the audiophiles and the minds
of the million people
it consumed holden miller and fred are
worried that this horror show might
spread
so they plan to take the giant mormon
spaceship the nauvoo
and slam it into eros to knock the whole
asteroid into the sun
ending the threat of the proto-molecule
miller sets up bombs on eros then he
chooses to stay there
he feels too tired and broken to ever
reconnect to humanity
miller just wants to die with julie he
watches
as the nauvoo the hammer of god fills
the sky
screams towards him then misses
the voice of eros shouts don't you
[ __ ] touch me and the whole asteroid
moves uses some alien force to dodge the
nauvoo
then eros starts moving towards earth
apparently to infect the population
but miller realizes that the ghostly
voice of eros
includes julie the eros proto-molecule's
mind
grew from julie it infected her
and she infected it deep in
eros miller finds the infected julie
she's controlling eros
dreaming that she's flying her ship the
razorback
when she says don't you [ __ ] touch me
she's remembering that time that she was
attacked
her memories and personality are
intertwined with the alien mind
so miller speaks with julie and
convinces her to fly eros to venus
instead of earth
he removes his helmet and lets the
proto-molecule take him
as he and julie and eros descend into
the clouds of venus
the cynical nihilistic miller finds
something to believe in
and holden is left a more mature an
experienced hero
able to question his idealistic view of
the world and himself
which helps him face the dangers of
later books
including what emerges from venus
so leviathan wakes explores different
perspectives on how to live in a complex
universe
rationality and cold realism gets [ __ ]
done
but love and belief give life meaning
the expanse is about futuristic
technology and fantastic worlds but it's
grounded in the same human
passions flaws and ideals that cause
conflict today
whether on earth or among the stars the
problems we have
are the ones we bring with us in the
expanse tv show miller finds a data
broker who hides a data chip
inside his own leg but there are easier
ways
to protect your data dashlane is a
password manager that generates and
remembers secure passwords for all your
sites
it's secure easy to use and free so sign
up to dashlane at the link below
you can also use the offer code for 10
off a premium membership which
includes syncing devices a vpn and a gig
of encrypted cloud storage
which is much more convenient than leg
storage
sign up below to help alt shift x and
help you stay
secure thanks for watching thanks to
expanse co-author daniel abraham for
help with the script
and to history of westeros and brandon
for feedback
thanks to patrons invisible floyd beth
quizada terry thomas fuzzy the fair
patrick brown
emac and hedwig cheers
you